Daniel can you explain to me in 30
seconds or less what you do to somebody
that's stupid like me now I know it has
something to do with math and in DNA and
medicine right so you know in the last
10 years all of these technologies have
been developed in biology that make it
possible for us to really understand on
a deep level what our cells are doing
and the question is can we translate the
data that we can now collect on a
cellular level into useful clinical
information that we can use to treat
disease to predict patient outcomes and
to do other really potentially useful
things so the question is can we develop
statistical methods in order to
translate this data into useful
knowledge that can have practical when
you're talking data we're talking about
the human DNA right yeah so one example
of data is the human genome where we can
now sequence an entire individual's DNA
but there's a lot of other types of data
too that we might be interested in and
these data types really share the
characteristic that they're incredibly
massive we might measure 3 million
measurements or 30,000 measurements for
a single individual and it's really just
a huge amount of data that honestly the
world hadn't seen before 10 years ago so
in my my DNA so we have base pairs that
are matched up right how many base pairs
are in mine or is it same for everybody
it's the same for everyone and it's you
know for you it's pretty similar to like
a chimpanzee also and that type of thing
but but how long are we talking to you
know early hears about sequencing the
you know DNA and that it's coming
cheaper and people are you know 23andme
and all this sort of stuff right so you
know traditionally people would on the
the technology that was in use five
years ago would involve measuring like
half a million base pairs because that
was the number of base pairs in which
there's really a lot of variation in the
human population but you don't measure
the whole thing they just measure the
bits that that change that's right well
more recently people have actually
started measuring the whole thing
because there are new technologies that
actually make it fast and cheap to
literally measure the entire thing to
sequence an individual's DNA instead of
just measuring the bits and pieces but
they could and this is amazing because
when the human genome was first
sequenced that was a huge endeavor that
took an incredible amount of work and
there was that one guy who kind of skin
head right but you know now these these
same things are possible on a much
faster and cheaper scale for an
individual so how is all this stuff
going to sort of change my life I mean
if I get sick if I got forbid you know
the big cancer word or something like
that and this happens in 20 years what
you're doing now is going to save me
right yeah that's right that's the
helpful the idea is right now there's a
lot of diseases that we know on a
molecular level are different we know
that not all breast cancers are the same
for instance but a lot of these diseases
are really treated pretty similar in two
different patients even though on a
molecular level these patients diseases
might be different and so the question
is can we really target therapy on the
basis of this large scale data in order
to give each person the treatment that
they're going to respond best to that's
pretty amazing stuff actually uh so
let's talk about success for a minute
and what that means so you're part of
our glamorous and wonderful 30 under 30
which is which is a fantastic group
you've had a pretty stellar academic
career and you're off doing some amazing
research now and you feel like you've
made it or you just starting out are you
going to go on to do what well it's a
long road I hope that I haven't made it
yet because there's a lots of questions
that would be boring right that's right
okay and I've got it I've got a career
ahead of me so you know there's there's
always more problems to answer and more
more areas to become an expert in and
what's fun about the research that I do
actually is that the skills that I have
as a statistician are really broad so
they can be applied to like studying and
better understanding cancer or they can
be applied to to high-tech and
understanding data from the internet and
stuff like that so there's always more
paths ahead last question you thinking
at any point about starting your own
company you know this is for us we like
the entrepreneurial spirit here well I'm
a statistician which means that I'm paid
to be a skeptic and you know so in most
startups fail is that what you're trying
to say it in nice well also you know I
wouldn't want to start something unless
I'm really sure that the data is there
and and you know that's something that
it'll take years yeah you know the
science has to progress and we really
have to get to the point we
we can reliably make inference and learn
things on the basis of these large data
sets so you don't go to Vegas much no I
don't thank you very much yeah